hey everybody how are you doing man
crystal you shop now
[Music]
I don't know what did this stand with
you yes yes come on come on this is
trappy he's a Leo
he enjoy long walks through the airport
right as well as long walks to the bank
he has a beautiful coat on the skin yes
yes I love nature I love animals I love
creation and I want to leave a legacy in
this world not just somebody just came
into the fur and leather business okay
one day the idea came that let's make a
fur coat for your dog so you match oh so
that's how you do it man
real-life fur coats for the dogs yes
where's Christopher is located Christos
first is located
104 11 the West set of my Claude in
Westchester Illinois
Illinois's man okay here we go now this
is the most expensive fur coat this is
the most expensive fur coat
let's do this right - you put the gloves
on the power you and you have - okay so
you're ready for this I'm excited to see
what you got going on okay let's see
this is a chinchilla sugar more for
action Sheila look at your look at that
moment that's not a dog boy that's not a
dollar short
sure it was okay and the whole thing
opens up chinchilla with the hood yes
sir look at this jacket a match not only
chinchilla with the hood but the inside
is perforated 100% leather so you can
reverse it now these are all natural
fibers no plastic stuff
let's keep America clean everybody keep
the environment clean don't wear plastic
don't wear plastic shoes plastic
clothing goes into the water system we
don't even know it goes into our food
chain there's another thing we have to
think we're
fur leather cashmere wool cotton that is
God give us plenty thank you so this is
the most expensive fur coat with crystal
zippers with a crystal soup now how much
would you say that for how much they no
sale
this is an sell for $10,000 if somebody
there comes with $10,000 cuz I'm gonna
check that much people really love their
animals their animals more than
ourselves so much
let me feel this it's solved
it's so soft sky's the limit if they ask
crystals first to cover the whole United
States from one end to the other you can
do we can do it from Street poles to
sidewalks or our seats our places it
doesn't matter you're talking [ __ ] but
yes that's true right I don't just say
it show me and I'll do it
Toki go green to agree can I give my
phone number it does if you wanted to
race those first seven one seven oh
eight
Mike Jones you have six two three eight
seven seven
you can't forget three eight seven seven
Spence first
okay